à deux ans des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de paris de nombreuses
interrogations révélations quant à la
maîtrise de leur organisation
s'accumulent les conclusions du rapport
du comité d'audit indique que seuls les
risques financiers liés à l'inflation
sur le coût des travaux il soit
clairement mentionné alors même que
l'explosion de certaines factures le
centre aquatique olympique 173 millions
au lieu de 90 l'aréna de la porte de la
chapelle 132 millions au lieu de 90
n'ont rien à voir avec ces inflations
tout comme les coûts engendrés par des
changements de site olympique de
dernière minute
interrogations aussi sur les questions
de sécurité publique parmi ces risques
figurent ceux pesant sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture sur la scène avec la
sécurisation sur plus de 6 kilomètres de
160 barge flottante
205 délégations étrangères dix mille
athlètes sans compter la présence de
nombreux chefs d'état et tout cela
devant 600 mille spectateurs
interrogations enfin sur la manière dont
les villes de paris gère ses jeux à ce
jour pas moins de cinq mille chantiers
gangrène la capitale de nombreux élus
parisiens avec l'âme davantage de
transparence dans la gestion de ce
dossier des jo sans réponse de la maire
de paris même l'ancien ministre champion
olympique guy drut alerte sur les
risques d'explosion de coûts et le
manque de concertation d'un budget
initial de 6 8 milliards d'euros celui
ci s'élève aujourd'hui à presque 8
milliards et le tient pas compte de la
garantie des 3 milliards apportés par
l'état il s'agit d'éviter que cette
grande fête populaire ne se transforme
en un immense fiasco
aussi prouver vous madame la première
ministre confirmé que le gouvernement a
pris la pleine mesure de ce dossier et
qu'il veille à sécuriser le cadre
budgétaire et financier des jeux comme
l'a réclamé la cour des comptes je vous
remercie